okay so this is the eight fallacies of
distributed computing my name is Steven
Asbury I work at fog Creek software on a
product called kiln whoo
okay there they are I used to work at a
company called TIBCO software which
turns out to one of the sponsors I had
no idea I worked in the messaging group
there before that I worked at the
pre-requisite startup that died in the
internet bus before that I worked at
next computer and before that I was a
grad student in nuclear engineering
which I finished somewhere in the midst
of those other bullets but I don't want
to admit where it was let's just say it
took me four decades to finish my PhD
but we'll move on so I first heard about
the eight fallacies at JavaOne a long
time ago from James Gosling and it turns
out they have this very rich history
which is cool and you can read about it
I'm using Wikipedia as if it's the truth
so I don't know maybe it is maybe it
isn't but anyway the eight fallacies I
think are a really good way to kind of
capture what's in people's subconscious
right the mistakes we make because it's
in our subconscious so most of my talk
is not gonna be big words so if you want
big words you should leave if you if you
know somebody who doesn't like big words
text them and have them come back in the
room so I can have a big audience so the
first thing fallacy is something that's
wrong like a wrong thinking a wrong
belief a bad idea and I'm gonna try to
stick with saying the fallacies as the
fallacies so if somewhere in the middle
of the talk you're like why is this guy
telling me something that is blatantly
not true that is my intention throughout
the entire talk if I say something
that's true by accident that's an
accident okay go back to the fallacies
the fallacies are the real thing the
second thing is I'm really trying to get
into your subconscious here I really
really want you to be scared when you
leave this talk that is my goal is to
scare you right so if you don't like
being scared you should leave now
boom backhoes very scary I'll tell you
why when I started working at next I
used to teach people how to program
objective-c and next step so I'd travel
around and we'd have a class and it
would be really fun one day I'm in
Michigan we're teaching a class to a
company I can't say the name
everything's going great I'm doing a
great job kind of like I am right here
it's really good everybody's happy and
the power goes out so we're looking
around what's going on what's going on
the emergency lights come up the
mainframe turns on that's how old I am
it's okay
we look outside and there's a backhoe
that just dug through the power cable
right the network is reliable fallacy
number one this is always true
boom the network is reliable in 2008
someone climbed down a manhole in San
Jose and cut through the fiber-optic
cable April 2008 in April 2013 someone
else did the exact same thing I don't
know about you I think it's something to
do with Texas okay the second fun part
of my talk this is fun not scary is I
have some little bonus prizes I don't
have a price you don't get anything if
you know where the pictures from shining
that was easy don't feel good about
yourself
it gets harder it gets harder boom
shirts the network is reliable Google
wraps their fiber-optic cables
why they have fiber-optic cables in the
ocean I don't know but they're Google
it's not my job
they wrap them in Kevlar and steel why
the Sharks like to eat them that doesn't
make any sense right
so I had to read about it it turns out
if you know anything about fiber optics
they have lasers you know light going
through a cable and it wears out over
time it's not perfect so the light gets
dimmer and dimmer and dimmer and then
you put a little repeater
but the repeater uses electricity so
they put an electric cable in with the
fiber-optic cable the electricity
creates a little electromagnetic field
around the cable now the cable looks
like food to a shark it looks actually
like distressed food that's like ah
because it's got this electromagnetic
field and so the shark tries to eat the
cable they have to protect the cable the
network is reliable fallacy number one
fallacy number two I can work this
projector thing latency is zero if
you've been to some of the other talks
on distributed computing you know what
latency is but let me just say it again
latency is time to travel on the network
basically right we measure it like time
from message to get from me to the other
place usually though when we do a test
we measure to get to the other place I'm
back because that's easier and because
clocks don't work really in distributed
systems so latency is the time it takes
to get from here to there and latency is
money to certain people okay spread
networks for those who've read flash
boys maybe or something else is a
company that laid a fiber optic line
from New York really New Jersey to
Chicago really I don't think Chicago but
somewhere near Chicago so that they
could get a faster connection between
the data centers for the traders they
shaved off a couple milliseconds
I want you to think about that a couple
milliseconds for which they paid
millions of dollars to make a slightly
straighter fiber-optic cable than the
one the phone company would give them
okay so they paid millions of dollars
for that let's just to compare if you
want to read from like an SSD it's like
a hundred microseconds from memories
like some number of nanoseconds so
millet we're like we're already ten
times what reading from disk and like a
hundred or more times from reading from
memory but they're paying money to move
it okay now here's the problem for
spread networks someone came back and
said hahahaha we're gonna build
something with towers and radio and it's
gonna go even straighter and they're
shaving more milliseconds off and
they're actually using millimeter waves
instead of mic instead of microwaves
because they can compress the data
better
so latency is zero
oh my bill didn't work Oh okay my
favorite latency is zero talk story
which may or may not be true I believe
it's true but with fakeness to it that's
okay because it's a good story so back
in the 90s
professor walks in to the sysadmin
office and says we can't send email more
than 500 miles if you haven't read this
story that is that the stupidest thing
you ever heard that doesn't make any
sense like if you're the sysadmin you're
like that is the dumbest thing I ever
heard
so he starts trying like I'm gonna send
some email so he sends it to a guy
across town works fine sends it a little
farther works fine right tries to send
it over 500 doesn't work no email try
ste thinks maybe it's like some weird
Geographic thing so like I'm gonna send
it to my friend but I know his mail
servers in Seattle so like I'm gonna
mail it it's gonna go farther and come
back to him but he's closer than 500
miles doesn't work so he goes and pokes
around and figures out that a consultant
we all know some of you may be
consultants I apologize but you guys
whatever okay so a consultant had
reinstalled an operating system upgraded
it and in the process upgraded
or actually downgraded the sendmail
program which caused the configuration
file that the main guy had put in didn't
work anymore so now all his timeouts
were wrong and it was using basically
some default timeout which in the story
is three milliseconds and if you do the
math three milliseconds is about 500
miles for traveling of light now go read
the story then read the fact because
there's like half the fact is that's not
real right like the speed of light in a
lot and copper is not the speed of light
in vacuum and blah blah blah and you
wouldn't know until it came back and so
you've got a double and the guys like
look it's a good story shut up so
latency a zero that pictures not from
anything it's just a good picture come
on okay latency is zero I used to work
at TIBCO and I made a classic Java
programmer distributed computing mistake
we had a situation we had a primary
server and we had a backup server sorry
I'm going in the dark we had a backup
server when you sent information to the
primary server it would not say it was
successful until the backup server had
said that it got the data that was great
and we were smart and we said we'll put
a timeout the problem is Java does
garbage collection so sometimes we would
say update from 1 to 2 and the primary
would say update from 1 to 2 and the
backup would go and the primary would
timeout and say we're staying at one but
the backup would go to 2 because right
that's distributed computing so the
lesson here latency isn't just about the
network the speed of light latency is
also about what the other machines doing
right and garbage collection that now if
you went to the Jetson talked earlier
you learned that elasticsearch did the
same thing I did but they did it with a
lot more money if I made as much as
they've had invested I wouldn't feel bad
I felt a little bad I don't feel bad
anymore I don't work there anymore
ok bandwidth is infinite
the network is reliable latency is zero
bandwidth is infinite
I can push as much data through the
network as I want and let me be clear
about bandwidth band and a sysadmin told
me to make sure I did this bandwidth is
data over time so it's how much stuff
you can push at it at a time we're gonna
talk in a little bit about the phone
company who calls bandwidth data times
time which is the total use of data but
data is bandwidth over time and it's
it's infinite so if you have a single
server through which everything passes
like a RabbitMQ server or a some single
database or anything like that and all
your data goes to that place you can do
whatever you want because you can push
all the data there and get it all back
all over the network all over the
internet with no problem
bandwidth is infinite so much so that
everything can depend on everything else
now I was starting to lie too much I
don't want to say that so one of the
nice things about Hadoop for people who
did that and even though it's I guess
getting out of style whatever I'm old so
Hadoop has this thing let's move the
work near the data and the reason one
reason to do that is instead of moving
data all over the network the data stays
where it is the work is small kind of
like what the last talk was about I move
the work near the data and I move only
the results back minimizing the amount
of bandwidth that I need to run my
application so if we can create things
that are separate we can avoid any
problems with the infinite amount of
bandwidth that is made available to us
by our phone company and the intranets I
didn't miss any fun slides today I don't
think so I don't think I missed any good
ones yet boom
bandwidth is infinite you know what
bandwidth is closer to infinite than
latency here's the problem with latency
once two things are this close together
that's it that's the latency you can't
get better than that latency unless you
do something which you will be very rich
for if you can do if you can bypass the
speed of
light which by the way TIBCO did with
their faster than light product FTL if
you can go faster than light you can
avoid latency problems but latency is
fixed right it's it's physics bandwidth
is money
latency is a little bit money but it's
mostly physics bandwidth this money if
you want to dig a tunnel and put a bunch
of fiber you can move more data over
time so there is one good thing about
bandwidth which is that you can expand
it if you have the money to do so
so the network's reliable latency is
zero bandwidth is infinite and the
network is secure the network is
SuperDuper secure some of you may have
heard about this little problem called
heartbleed and what happened was there
was a little bug nothing big where you
could send a request to a server and say
I'm sending you a packet that's a
thousand whatever bytes and then you
just send them one byte and they'd say
okay here's your thousand bytes and so
you'd get a random 999 bytes back from
whatever was in memory now that wouldn't
seem too bad except most of the time
people's SSL stuff is near their
authentication stuff so you might get a
password you might get a username you
might get something good heartbleed a
little bit scary just a little right
it's fixed don't worry all servers have
fixed heartbleed there's no more
problems the network is secure the
network is secure ok there have been
over 10 or 30 excuse me over 30 known
episodes of someone getting over 100k
usernames account information whatever
in the last 10 years
eBay lost over 145 million user accounts
some things recently homedepot just said
they lost 45 million like in the last
three months somebody hacked them
somebody hacked JPMorgan Chase for the
last three months or six months nobody
knows we don't know but they got
something we don't know what it is but
it's bad and we think the other Bank had
it happened too but we don't know for
sure the network is secure from hackers
what movie I gave you a hint it's not a
TV show nobody knows the Great Train
Robbery thank you beautiful movie come
on people the network is secure okay
the network is secure now when I made
this slide I thought to myself I'm gonna
write down in Google Image Search
celebrity photo hack my wife is sitting
right there that was a mistake okay
so most of you know probably more than
even knew about heartbleed know about
the celebrity photo hack the celebrity
photo hack happened a little while ago
at first everybody thought it was iCloud
it turns out it was probably just
regular old password hacking some people
- naked pictures of themselves
put it up on iCloud I don't understand
my wife's response was why did they take
the pictures in the first place and why
did they put him up on iCloud I don't
know but they did and then their
password got hacked and the network is
secure it's reliable the latency is zero
the bandwidth is infinite and it's
completely and utterly secure even
better if you have a problem on the
Internet
on your network you oh no I oh I forgot
I have one more slide before I do that
second topology doesn't change now okay
who knows what this is from
nobody's gonna know come on TMP oh come
on I had to come up with a slide just to
put this picture in it okay who can
guess what I want to talk about the cap
theorem come on people it's a cap
okay okay topology doesn't change one
whole part of the cap theorem is all
about topology partition tolerance it's
the part you can't ignore because it's
the one part that's based on the fact
that there is a sharp a backhoe and a
guy with a freaking axe out there trying
to make your data center not work the
way you want it to anybody who says the
topology doesn't change I'm gonna say I
just said it that's terrible
topology doesn't change okay this is a
hard one this is from a game based on a
movie I'll give it to you it's a
Ghostbusters game I couldn't find a good
Ghostbusters picture recently few years
ago fog Creek had a problem their router
decided something about spanning tables
I don't know
I'm not a sysadmin okay I'm a programmer
so for me topology doesn't change I'm a
programmer it everything's perfect right
but for the sysadmin something happened
with spanning tables for those who know
what that means and the network packets
started going in a big loop and
everything went to hell right they had a
big packet flood they called it which i
think is an awesome name I could have
put a flood I guess instead of
ghostbusters I don't know topology
doesn't change topology doesn't change
sometimes I wanted a guy with you know
but whatever plumber sometimes topology
changes in a good way you do an upgrade
or maybe you take out a machine you
don't need anymore and you save some
money recently the current product I'm
working on we I admit we had a problem
with our deployment script and it
assumed that there were three servers so
when we ran deploy one two three they're
all okay good deploy work the admin said
we don't need three servers we only need
two servers we'll take one server and
we'll put it somewhere else and do
something good with it cool deploy fail
why the deploy fail deploy fail because
there's only two servers right topology
changing can come up just in weird
places right e for reasons you meant to
change the topology maybe you did it
maybe you did if you went to the
see now gent Jensen Jen yeah whatever
you know what I'm talking about call me
maybe I love that stuff oh man if you
went to the talk awesome
terrifying partitioning terrible stuff
topology doesn't change the network is
reliable latency is zero
bandwidth is infinite the network is
secure and topology doesn't change I
don't even know how much time I have
let's see
there is one administrator to take care
of you though that was what I meant to
do my intro before but I messed up so
there's one administrator one guy you
have to talk to no matter what right am
i right maybe you work at a company with
one guy you're the administrator not me
I work at a company with a whole bunch
of systems I'm like ok I want to do the
deployment deploy system one failed you
don't have authentication hey can I get
authentication is there someone cool
thanks due to a deployed boom failed
system - hey can I get authentic Asian -
system - ok good
you see where this goes right so there's
authentication across things now if you
want you can work at a company where
they have single sign-on which gets you
to the picture one of the single sign-on
systems Kerberos named after Cerebus
something like that
The Guardian - the gates of Hell who was
defeated soundly by Harry Potter come on
people
Harry Potter and Hermione and the other
guy
there is one administrator and his name
is Edward Snowden okay look no politics
if you have an administrator they can do
bad things
they can do good things in the case of a
company or a government agency bad is
whatever you don't want right in the
case of the country maybe it's what you
did one I'm not saying anything about
Edward Snowden good or bad but he did
take a lot of documents from here and
put them over here and the people who
owned this machine were very unhappy
right so there is one administrator in
fact he was one of thousands of
administrators I don't even know man
that's all my money to tax dollars
there's one administrator boom okay
what's the reference Blazing Saddles you
got it for those who can't tell the guy
holding the gun on the Left is the guy
on the left like that okay
in 2008 in San Francisco there was a
network administrator named Terry childs
he built this fiber land that was
awesome
I guess that's what everybody says
including him he built this awesome
thing and then they kind of pushed him
out and somebody else took over there
was like kerfuffle I don't know what
happened I don't know who's in the right
or wrong but Terry child's walked away
with all the passwords to all the
routers for the fiber man that nobody
else knew so San Francisco could not
manage its own network they put Terry
childs in jail he said I will give the
passwords to the mayor Gavin Newsom
who's now the lieutenant governor who's
probably gonna be President someday
I'm just saying so Gavin had to go to
the jail and ask can you give me the
passwords he said sure I'll give you the
passwords boom here they are they got
control of their network again right
there's one administrator kind of scary
if he has the passwords great scene by
the way great movie Blazing Saddles I'm
gonna give it an ADD BAM transport cost
is zero
the network is reliable latency is zero
bandwidth is infinite the network is
secure
topology doesn't change there's one
administrator and transport cost is zero
that's why net fit netflix paid Comcast
to improve the performance of their
streaming not you know not to pay for
the streaming or anything just maybe
something I don't know and you might
think well that's nothing but they also
paid Verizon they paid AT&T and they
paid I think other companies as well for
the same thing to get more transport
transport cost is zero boom
nobody knows what ok this is a picture
from the Tour de France I wish I had a
prize for whoever could name the guy in
green no come on please
Contador is about half his size it's
Peter Sagan ok I won't ask you who the
other guy is cuz there's no chance ok
here's the thing transport cost a zero
about six or seven years ago hotel Wi-Fi
wasn't that great like it is today I
mean today it's good you know so
I used to travel a lot more and I went
and got myself a little mobile broadband
and I said well if I'm gonna get a
mobile broadband what I don't want to do
is pay for the data I want to pay a
price and that's it so I went and looked
around and sprint said we'll give you
mobile broadband 3G 5 gig limit 4G
all-you-can-eat sign me up
got it boom a couple years later my wife
went to Cleveland to visit her parents
the Tour de France was on for those who
don't know the Tour de France involves
for the fans three to six hours of
watching TV for 22 days in a row in the
summer in July so you basically can't
work during that time because you if you
have a TiVo you can watch it at night
but it's literally your whole life for
that time let alone for the athletes you
know whatever they get paid I watch this
because I love it so my wife sets up the
thing I said make sure you're on 4G so
she goes and you know it's up here and
it's over there and it's 4G and it's
great and we get our bill $400 I like
what the hell
$400 unlimited 4G I call sprint oh we
changed that you didn't tell me change
oh we told you I go through all my bills
on the back and little bitty texts no
longer unlimited I cancelled that okay
transport cost is zero just think of
Peter Segond that's the guy eating your
money transport cost is zero one way to
think about transport cost is latency
you can also think of it as bandwidth
but like I said you can buy bandwidth
you can't really buy latency too well so
the way you get latency is by something
the high frequency traders call bit F
word something I can't say it in
am I getting trouble so bit twiddling
that's not what it is
I used to work at Tim Cohen I worked on
a protocol to FTL like I said it moves
faster than light it was a brilliant
messaging thing but in order to do FTL
and in order to get Layton sees under a
microsecond when accessing memory is
measured in tens of nanoseconds you just
you can't use locks you only you know
like the time of a message round-trip
was the equivalent of 20 mutex locks
like you can't use locks you can't do it
right you have to just get down in every
line of code go can I get rid of that
line of code can I do it it's very
expensive and very painful but transport
cost is zero the network is reliable
latency is zero bandwidth is infinite I
want to make sure I go in the right
order network is secure
topology doesn't change there's one
administrator and transport cost is zero
the network is homogeneous who believes
the network is homogeneous this is the
easiest one come on nobody believes this
anymore I mean you're here you got a
phone and you're trying to do Wi-Fi you
know it's not homogeneous let me give
you my thing what's the movie
it's Tron yeah Tron Legacy what do I
know
come on I just looked for a picture that
reminded me of those people with fiber
optics to their house if any of you are
those people I don't talk to you okay I
pay a cable company a nice monopoly
amount of money to get crappy connection
to my house right but not everybody has
that most people today have phones the
network is homogeneous which is why
Facebook paid some ungodly billions of
dollars for whatsapp which actually runs
on phones that aren't smartphones right
and other things because writing an app
to run on smartphones isn't as hard as
writing an app to run on some weird
Nokia thing that somebody in the middle
of who knows where is using who knows
save by the book you know all of them
heroes oldest me you can't answer
anymore you can't answer any more Saved
by the Bell who remembers those phones
man I wanted one of those phones those
were the
coolest when they came out I mean come
on okay the network is homogeneous oh
this is the hardest one to ask oh come
on you're right okay fine
so the network is homogeneous which is
why Google bought a company a purifier
or something and they also built into
the new Chrome network simulators which
Mac also has in their network system
Systems Preferences panel if you want to
play with it network simulator so you
can try what it's like to run your app
on a system that doesn't have the same
bandwidth as the network you're actually
on and if you're a web programmer that's
a really great thing to do if you're a
mobile developer that's a really great
thing to do if you happen to work in a
data center where everything is perfect
and you have fiber interconnects between
all of your machines and multiple
private networks with routers and
bridges I don't want to talk to you
anymore and that's fine
but there are simulators also a good
movie so those are the eight fallacies
how'd I do on time good the network is
reliable latency is zero bandwidth is
infinite the network is secure
topology doesn't change there's one
administrator transport cost is zero and
the network is homogeneous there's also
a monitor right there I could look at
instead of looking at the screen yeah so
those are the eight fallacies they
really capture right the problems with
distributed computing I mean if you went
to any of the other talks something they
were talking about is because of one of
these somebody ignored one of these or
intentionally just bypassed one of them
or didn't think or somebody's making a
lot of money by fixing these right I
mean like you can't fix them but
somebody's out there going you know
latency isn't zero so I'm gonna be smart
and make something that's low latency
and then I'm gonna sell it to high
frequency traders and make lots and lots
and lots and lots of money so a couple
things from the real world I listened to
some talks and I'm glad Corbis dead I
think
RMI is almost dead
but here's the problem with Corbin our
my and all the other distributed object
systems and all the things where people
say hey we're gonna hide the network
from you is that everything that hides
the network from you hides all of the
fallacies from you right and they're all
there I mean it hides all the realities
is what it really hides so it assumes
all the fallacies and says no no you can
just make an object and send messages to
it it's fine
it's not fine a simple thing I mean I
just think about this like I used to
teach distributed objects on next it was
the coolest thing in the world I mean I
did a great demo where like in three
lines of code you're sending messages
between apps I mean it was awesome how
did you set the timeout no there was no
timeout okay web sockets and polling so
you know things like latency and
reliability require things like
reconnecting and other things and you
got to think about that right they also
require things like timeouts which means
that if you want to you can cheat and
set timeout so all your tests pass and
then somebody garbage collects and then
your tests you know your production
fails so timeouts a good way to get
around a lot of the realities of
networking but not so good the bottom
line is you should trust physics okay
that's why I went got a PhD in nuclear
engineering so that I could do computing
right that's why now I understand like
copper speed of light okay I got it good
okay trust physics read the docs and
then test if the docs are true I don't
know some people don't tell the truth in
their docs and the truth is unless
you're running on real time systems all
of the things about latency are real
they can happen on the other side if
you're on a real time system then maybe
they won't happen on the other side
maybe they'll only happen in the middle
but I don't work on real time systems
and I'm gonna bet that 99% of people in
the room don't work on real time systems
and I mean hard real time systems I
don't mean the ones that you know like
as software developers we say we're
gonna do some real time
or something like that so I would highly
suggest everybody go back and watch the
jibsen - electric Boogaloo talk which is
a reference to break into electric
Boogaloo which is also maybe not a great
movie certainly not as good as the
original breakin so those are the
fallacies let's be careful out there
Hill Street Blues thank you okay
questions comments or just applause